okay make sure you mute the stream if we
are playing one another don't be a sneak
artist no c5 Sicilian land okay close
Sicilian I guess we're having f4 and
okay let's let's go with this it's the
Grand Prix attack ecl code b20 34
curious to learn more about it I don't
know how much I can really offer e 6 97
now that is that strikes me is off all
right I'm not not too concerned about
that wait a second there's some tactics
may be against the bishop night here now
I take the bishop the night gives a
check i could play here there might be
some issue against that but i think i
should be i think that that should be
quite all right i'll be castled soon
enough and my bishop will be defended um
I b5 Bishop takes Bishop Knight check
King f8 night g5 hating at this square i
think there's got to be something good
for it on me let's see hopefully there
is ok now that the bishop is defended
let's go here and night be five well it
wouldn't be coming to d6 with check at
that point so my opponent is this is
strictly preventative for one thing and
i could post up on d4 with tempo on the
bishop and be honest i think i like that
there is a concern with the grand prix
at actually this this is this is off the
idea of playing be to the typical grand
prix idea of castling Queenie one Queen
h4 with f5 and getting the bishop to h6
that's something I don't have any fear
of of course since the bishop is on this
different diagonal I could take the
bishop I could pick up the bishop hair
and then follow with d5 Knight takes
Knight takes exchange dark squared
Bishop saz a consideration because it
could I say it kind of feeding kiddos
that rook makes it look a bit silly for
one and if the position could maybe open
up in files that your files can open up
okay maybe that's not going to be a good
spot probably not going to be a good
spot but anyhow my other candidate moves
take the night probably not d5 maybe a
six yeah actually a six I think I might
like a six with b5 expansion or just d5
know d 5 e 5 my bishop is shut out of
the game I think if I five now I play
something like d6 and break that break
this down I'm gonna go with a six let's
see how that Bishop reacts I spent quite
a bit of time in that last move what is
he going to do c4 is probably not a good
option taking the night is definitely
not a good option because I recaptured
the pond and there's two minor pieces
hit one of them will fall ok I think I
might still want to go with this just to
get my light squared Bishop on this
diagonal
hmm
this has my concern actually this pawn
push I think I want might want to be in
the spot to take it or maybe I get my
night doing something else over here
right here isn't that you're gonna be an
issue I want to get my bishop on this
diagonal let's let's see what light does
this this has my attention the e5 push
in what should maybe also have my
attention is f5 that could be a bit
disruptive to my Kings side I'll
consider if f 5 i'll consider taking e
takes f but i'll really shy away from
taking with my jeep on those of you that
were here a few streams ago will know
that i took a beating from the chest
chief in the Simon I was playing the
black side and I believe there was that
FF pond push was not the same position
of course much much much different here
but uh the f5 push has my attention in
short so I think just swing the back
completely around you do b-52 expand and
develop the bishop so I'm looking at
maybe f5 myself i'm looking at d6 I am
how to recapture with my bishop or my
pawn I think I like the bishop actually
with check hmm yeah i'm gonna go with
this kick the king of the corner he's on
the same diagnose my bishop and i think
i want to follow up with this yeah now i
don't have to worry about f5 I don't
know how great a move it would be but
I'm looking to break it g2 in fact if
pond takes I might want to actually take
well by default i'm considering
capturing towards the center there is i
do have some i'm hesitant with may be
doing that because it does open up an
avenue for the white pieces against my
king but i might want to throw my king
in the corner and then play rook g8
ideas and it may seem a bit awkward to
want to do that seeing how this guy is
on the diagonal but I'm viewing these
bishops other position right now I'm
doing the
as negating one another I I'm
anticipating that the darts for bishops
are just going to be off the board in
many instances when you're left with
just one Bishop you want to have your
pawns on the opposite color complex of
your remaining Bishop but I think
there's some merit to actually still
having this pawn on a light square
anticipating a dark square Bishop
exchange again because of putting
pressure on first and foremost efore but
maybe even g2 and yeah what am I getting
at what do I want to do what is my what
can my night do better what can he do
better I don't know i'm not sure what
could my queen doe she did she's doing
nothing she's she's bad maybe my night
wants to be on this square King in the
corner right now night g8 to f6 little
scary let's give it a shot let's give it
a shot with this move I'm pretty much
saying I'm not going anywhere but this
diagonal with my bishop ok so the darks
your bishops are off and now I think I
want to increase my pressure i'm going
home for just a moment i want to
increase my pressure on this poem notice
that with this Bishop obstructing d
there's no way to really reinforce this
as soon as I throw an additional piece
on it ok now I'm going to let that pawn
be taken I want to get pressure on the a
file and if pawn takes this is going to
be bad news for white i'm pretty sure
i'm also down about a half a minute
there just throw my knight in there if i
take here this night is going to make
use of this square let's see actually
let me throw up but the night here queen
out could be very very strong could be
very strong actually it could maybe be
leading to me because this pound is
pinned and powerless so h3 really
doesn't defend right now h3 is not
defending because it leads to a matin to
this is something i believe that white
mist and white will have to give up the
queen for the night in order to save the
game but that's just prolonging i
believe what is the inevitable h3 is a
mating to this pond is pin that was
missed that's going to be a matin to on
h2 nothing to do but move their next
move is me okay um good game let's see a
very very tense middle game we're both
looking for plans and that is not that
is far from the easiest thing to do
especially in a blitz game let's see
about this one so Sicilian closed Grand
Prix I don't know i haven't seen really
this Bishop b2 idea it's not losing but
it's just um it's certainly a typical
trying to get rid of a very important
ingredient for black the most the most
valuable as soon as I go with the
kingside few quetta the most valuable
minor piece really without him my king
definitely be vulnerable but it wasn't
really a way to exploit my king position
I'm just not sure I'm not sure let's see
well maybe maybe things are actually
okay at that very MF final position
bring your Bishop all the way back I'm
gaining space on the queenside move my
night with check your king is now in the
corner was there ever a possibility what
I'm kind of what I'm doing right now is
trying to find different points of the
game where there might have been
opportunities for certain pond advances
could certainly change the complexion of
the game for example right now instead
of a 383 is strictly preventive pretty
much saying okay you don't want to allow
me to get to be four but if I really
want to get to be 4 i'm going to get
there with tempo on the night whether or
not you capture right away your night
will eventually be kicked so I don't
know how useful a three is so I guess
just kind of skimming this game a three
is something to maybe not do don't have
that as a candidate move what about a
541 to shut down my bishop and be in a
position to meet be4 with 94 in fact
if if white is to play 'if I've here I'm
not going to be playing be four because
I'm just kicking the night to ask where
he might have already wanted to go to so
what might i do maybe e5 is worth
considering right now as soon as I'm
threatening to keep the night away what
about a five right now you get to e4 I
have to worry about d6 for sure although
II five does allow tonight f5 but I
don't know what I would really even be
doing there be 59 f five maybe you're
still going to e4 in fact you're not
just dying d6 you're putting pressure on
c5 maybe this is starting to see more
than one good reason to go forward with
this advance this is something to
consider if you aren't considering and I
think it's certainly worth consideration
maybe knowing that maybe knowing that in
this position right here I shouldn't be
going with B five maybe maybeee five
turns out to be so good I should have
been going with d6 right now tough to
say I don't want to devote to too much
attention it is just a blitz game but
good game darts for bishops come off I
think I was as clear as I could be with
throwing liking in the corner knowing
that the dark square Bishop start to
come off and at this point right here I
think you need to actually bring your
king back to g1 capturing this is just
going to be there's nothing to do h3
doesn't solve anything it's beat at this
point is what i'm getting at so the last
last point to really make the King has
to make use of g 1 i'm pretty sure right
now or you have to stop my queen from
coming out to h4 or maybe maybe right
now actually you could do h3 and after
Queen h4 you do king g one actually
maybe that's the better order my first
suggestion was here King g1 but what
about h3 most direct you're hitting the
night I have to do something Queen h4
King g1 you're once again threatening
the night has to do something I have to
eventually play back to h6 and then and
then you have something against this
pond
and once he's out of there then of
course you're able to make use of fc4
and then d 6 I would be on a three but
it's okay you have to do something about
that and that's going to be a way to
defend its easy easy one to miss that
pond being pinned h3 turns out to just
not defend okay couple quick points is
all let me close out